Please welcome Padma Lakshmi.
(crowd cheers)
Mwaah I am sending you lots hugs and kisses,
Its so lovely to met you.
I am so happy to met you, I love you so much.
Thank you should we sit down?
Okay
(all laughs)
Welcome home.
This is so beautiful.
I can't believe your crystal ball that you had,
which is just who you are,
your authentic self with "Taste the Nation" that erupted
during a time when particularly this country said,
please recognize everybody.
And then you premiere with this show
that is about people's cultures.
Did it feel like soothing to know
you were obviously so on the right track?
I've always been interested
in knowing the different cultures of people
who live around me, my neighbors,
my friends, and around the world.
So this was just really an extension of that.
And I'm happy that
during the height of the pandemic,
it gave people a lot of comfort and entertainment and solace
and hopefully taught them about their neighbors
and fellow townspeople.
These immigrant communities that we go to,
they're nestled in different parts of the country,
but they're just like us,
they're American.
They want the same things and we often are afraid
to walk across the street or get to know them.
So that's really what the show is about.
It's about getting to know all Americans and understanding
that everybody's story is interesting and compelling.
You just have to tell it the right way,
you just have to listen, at least they're interesting,
compelling to me.
I took a bet that they'd be interesting to others as well.
Well I tell two people who are glad
they have crystal balls, Hulu and Bravo,
(Padma laughs)
because Hulu put on "Tastes the Nation."
And it's just a juggernaut show
everybody's talking about it.
And Bravo is sure happy because they said
"We actually have this other show," tell me about that.
Yeah, exactly I pitched another show to them,
and they said, "Well,
we want to do a different kind of show.
We think your idea is great,
but it's a little too high brow for us.
So would you be interested in developing this show with us,"
which was "Top Chef."
(Drew screams)
(crowd applauds)
Yeah, thank you.
My favorite show on television.
Thank you, thank you.
I would re-watch seasons, like that's-
Yeah, everybody did that during pandemic,
they watched...
I've been on top chef now for 15 years.
There's 18 seasons we're about to go film our 19th,
and it's just great.
I'm so happy that people still love it,
and it was fun for me, and I think that shows.
We get the privilege of what we see you do,
how you let us in, but you as a human being,
I love your relationship with your daughter.
I think you're such a good mom.
I was told I could never have children
because of endometriosis.
And so I savor every day with my child
because I know how lucky I am to have her.
I had five surgeries, I had a fallopian tube removed.
I had part of my right ovary removed.
So there's just basically rabbit ears and tinfoil
connecting everything together so...
(both laugh)
And yet those TV's work.
Yeah exactly.
I don't even know how she came into this earth
because she's such a miracle.
So I always knew I wanted to be a mom,
I never knew I would have so much fun.
I'm lucky in that I do have a tight relationship with her,
I'm very honest with her.
I try to remember that every day she's growing
in a different person than she was last week, and so am I.
And so I try to just come to her as she is
and figure out how I can give her what she needs
on that day or on that week, because it's different.
And so I remember being in fifth grade and sixth grade,
I remember being bullied, I remember having anxiety,
I remember feeling like no one was gonna like me,
I remember being terrified of opening my lunchbox,
cause my mom would put some weird Indian Curry leftovers,
and everyone else was having bologna sandwiches.
Oh I'm sure the other kids were so nice about that.
Oh yeah they were great.
But now I have a show about telling you about all that.
Exactly.
So there you go,
that's my revenge.
(applause)
Because it helped actually.
I had a conversation with Olive today
because I couldn't find my night guards on my side table,
I grind.
I have night guards too, because I grind too
It's terrible.
Padma, you just made me feel really good about myself
and my life, because I was literally going
you are so unsexy with the night guards,
at one point I had a neck brace on.
It was a triple threat.
(both laugh)
And not Olympic style.
And so, I couldn't find them and I said,
"Olive did you do something with them?"
And she goes, "Don't accuse me."
And I of course, not of course I actually did find them
somewhere else.
And I came back into the kitchen and I said,
"Olive I wanna explain something to you.
For years, you took stuff and you would damage it,
you would paint it, you would put it somewhere else."
This is what kids do, and I wasn't always the strictest
who was like, took that and taught her a lesson.
I kind of lived through a lot of her messes
and there was slime everywhere and the cat-
Oh yeah, there's slim everywhere it's just-
Everything is at carpets, that stuff,
and I'm a stain removal specialist.
I'm telling you slime-
Oh great cover to my house
because we have a few stains on my white rug
and that I need help with.
Don't tempt me.
I'm serious, I'm serious I just got a puppy,
she's not a puppy she's a rescue.
That's right.
In November
Divina.
Davina, exactly and Davina is divine,
but every once in a while, she's challenging.
And you live in Manhattan.
Yeah.
So yeah.
And I came to her and I said, "Listen,
I found them, so I just wanna say,
I'm used to years of anxiety where things go missing
and they get damaged,
but you've turned this incredible corner
and you're not doing that now, and I'm so proud of you.
So please understand it's gonna take me a minute."
but it's just, when you said they're not the same person
last week and neither are you.
I had that very moment with my daughter this morning
and I just had a really real talk.
So I really appreciate hearing that from you
because it's gonna make me a better parent.
I was wondering, now that I've taken this motherly advice
from you, you're such a goddess.
And I'm a single mom.
I was just curious, do you have any dating advice?
I never think about it,
but I don't know what I'm doing out there.
I don't either is the truth.
(all laugh)
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I barely have time to date
and I wish I had some secret sauce
to give you the recipe on that about,
but I really don't, I think it's very very hard.
I'm a 51 year old woman.
By the way, it was your birthday yesterday.
Yes it was.
(crowd applause)
Thank you, thank you.
I saw this picture of you and you said, "This is 51."
It is one of the most beautiful pictures I've ever seen
of you in my life.
Thank you, it was taken in my bedroom,
I did my makeup myself.
I was just not feeling like putting up
another bikini picture.
I know that's the requisite that everyone does.
And so that's how I was feeling.
And at 50, you are a different person.
I just want companionship, I don't want to be married,
I don't wanna live with anybody,
I don't need anything from anybody except their good company
and inspiration and their friendship.
And some gnocchi, but like-
(crowd laughs)
You know what?
This just makes me feel less crazy
because I have been so drawn to you
and everything you're saying is validating the way I feel.
And I just love you and getting to know you,
it turns out I'm not crazy.
And I do love you and you are everything
I ever hoped you would be,
(crowd applause)
(upbeat music)